[Applause]
dominating the agenda at edinburgh's
gathering of the big names in
broadcasting the future of the bbc from
its former presenter emily maitlis in
her keynote speech a stark warning of
the manipulation of the press by those
in power
we
journalists management teams
organizations are primed to back down
even apologize to prove how
journalistically fair we are being
and that can then be exploited by those
crying
bias director general tim davey has put
impartiality top of his agenda a
particular bugbear of boris johnson's
government said to be enraged by not
least the bbc's coverage of brexit
to a backdrop of government plans to
abolish the licence fee
a culture secretary who is a vocal
critic and government influence over bbc
appointments such as sir robbie gibb on
the corporation's board theresa may's
former advisor
put this in the context of the bbc board
where another active agent of the
conservative party
a former downing street spin doctor and
former advisor to bbc rival gb news now
sits
acting as the arbiter of bbc
impartiality
according to the financial times he's
attempted to block the appointment of
journalists he considers damaging to
government relations
emily maitlis appeared to be referring
to sir robbie gibb on the bbc board
theresa may's former advisor but in a
statement the bbc told sky news that the
assertion about a board member's role in
selecting journalists is totally
incorrect and the the board itself has a
collective responsibility to protect the
bbc's independence
also in edinburgh bbc chairman richard
sharp a tory donor once richie soon asks
boss at goldman sachs are you not afraid
at all of of government interference
no i will deal with that
i mean i will communicate with
government effectively and i expect i'm
pretty confident they will listen
and
because they as i said they value the
bbc
in the face of distrust and
disinformation impartiality is a complex
challenge for all broadcasters many of
whom are at this year's tv festival
historian david olasoga thinks there
the rules of engagements that emerged in
the history of television news were
based on an era before the post treaty i
don't think our
procedures our presumptions our fit for
purpose
so in the pursuit of truth and
impartiality in maitland's view the
press is paralyzed by those in power
seeking to further their own agenda
katie spencer sky news in edinburgh